well a fascinating new piece in vanity
fair magazine which is a garbage
publication but this is a good piece
outlines how jeffrey epstein made some
of his most powerful friends and how he
managed to stay so protected cocooned
for so long even as he was molesting
children
the piece is called the mogul and the
monster inside jeffrey epstein's
decades-long relationship with his
biggest client
well tonight we're learning much more
about the people jeffrey epstein
targeted brittany henderson
is a lawyer she's representing 67 of
jeffrey epstein's alleged victims
she's the co-author of relentless
pursuit our battle with jeffrey epstein
we're happy to have her on tonight
brittany thanks so much for joining us
good evening for having me oh it's it's
our pleasure this
is such an interesting story and i think
it's undercover for whatever reason
uh let's start with this vanity fair
piece i i you know i have no
other knowledge other than this story
but it says that les
wexner who's one of the biggest clothing
retailers in the country was essentially
the guy who funded the whole epstein
operation do you think that's true
so this this article tucker is exactly
what we
like to see there are three categories
of people that i think it's important we
talk about
it's the abusers the enablers and then
the friends of jeffrey epstein and
the friends fall into a category where
you had jeffrey epstein this man
masquerading as a money manager
in new york city a wealthy guy who had
so many people
on his side these friends of jeffrey
epstein
are the people who were on his island
who were in his house at dinner
those same people were having
conversations with women who we now know
were sexually trafficked by epstein and
sexually abused
those friends including les wexner are
the people who need to come forward and
speak up
i wonder why they they haven't been
forced to
i mean there are apparently hundreds
maybe thousands of hours of close
circuit tv
footage from epstein's various
properties that are still under seal for
some reason will we ever find out
who exactly was involved in whatever
scam he was running
and what they did those are exactly the
questions that we want answers to and we
believe that the people of power that
were in his orbit the people who were in
the dining room who were seeing the
things that were happening if they would
come forward and share what they know
and if they aren't
themselves abusers or enablers of the
abuse there's no reason that they
shouldn't do that so there are
ongoing criminal investigations which of
course we can't discuss much
much of tonight but it's those very
investigations that we hope
will yield the answers to your questions
do you have any idea what bill clinton
was doing there
and some english prince and i mean there
were not just a few but like a lot of
very famous people hanging around
jeffrey epstein was it i mean to be
blunt was it the sex i assume
or was it something else there are
individuals such as prince andrew who
have been accused by very credible women
such as virginia roberts of sexual
misconduct
there are also a number of other
individuals wealthy powerful
famous people who were flying on jeffrey
epstein's private plane
and friends with this very exciting and
energetic person who were not themselves
abusers and we think
as representatives of the victims and
speaking for the victims who themselves
believe it's important to
kind of distinguish between the
tabloidish type
information and really distill down who
was
abusing women and we think that those
other individuals who
had power and had money and were hanging
around but weren't doing anything wrong
those are the people that now can help
piece together the last stages of this
investigation
and really help us obtain justice for
women who have been fighting
for almost two decades to do just that
boy i really appreciate how precise you
are about that
and how direct and honest you are i mean
people who didn't do anything wrong
shouldn't be accused of wrongdoing and i
think that's an important distinction to
make just in the interest of fairness so
thank you for saying that
brittany thanks for coming on hope to
see you again
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else